-Well, the Republican meltdown
in the House
just keeps on getting
more humiliating for the party
and, specifically,
for GOP Leader Kevin McCarthy,
who has now, as of this taping,
lost eight consecutive votes
to become speaker,
leaving one of two chambers
of Congress in total paralysis,
as Republicans and Fox News
hosts bicker with each other,
stab each other in the backs,
and call each other names.
And I got to say,
it's pretty fun to watch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's just step back
for a minute
and remember all the predictions
of what Republicans thought
would happen this week.
On the back of a massive
midterm red wave,
the GOP would sweep into power
and anoint Kevin McCarthy
as the forceful new speaker
of the House,
who would use the GOP's
new position of strength
to go on the offensive
against Joe Biden
and the Democrats.
McCarthy even repeatedly
made a very bizarre joke
about wanting
to hit Nancy Pelosi
with the speaker's gavel
when she, inevitably,
handed it over to him,
although, it didn't always
make sense.
-Reporting about comments made
by Minority Leader McCarthy
about Nancy Pelosi
during a Tennessee GOP dinner
last night,
some pretty shocking audio
that we're getting right now.
Listen to this.
[ Whistling and applause ]
I want you to watch
Nancy Pelosi hand me that gavel.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
And I promise you this --
I won't bang her with it,
but I'll bang the end
to the socialism
and yes to America.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you
sure you didn't bang yourself
with it?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'll bang the end
to the socialism
and yes to America."
I can't believe that soaring
message didn't resonate.
[ Laughter ]
He has the same broken syntax
as a Norwegian tourist looking
for the M&M store.
[ Norwegian accent ]
Can you say where is the store
of the chocolate circles
who mouth melt without doing
the same to one's hands?
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, McCarthy and the GOP
were full of bravado
about how they would seize
the gavel
in a show of Republican power
and confront Joe Biden
and the Democrats.
Instead, we got
this split screen --
feuding Republicans in utter
chaos on the House floor,
while Joe Biden
was eating peach cobbler
[ Laughter ]
at a barbecue joint
in Cincinnati.
[ Applause ]
The only way
that could've been any more fun
for Biden right now is
if he was eating
his peach cobbler
while sitting in the back row
of the House of Representatives.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And you know
Biden's the kind of guy
who gets every last bite
of cobbler.
He'd be back there loudly
scraping his fork
around the sides
of his little dish.
[ As Biden ]
Hey, sorry! I know you gang
are trying to find a speaker.
It's just this is
some damn good cobbler.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They call me
the Cobbler Gobbler.
[ Laughter ]
It's yet another reminder
you can't underestimate
Joe Biden.
A lot of people thought he was
some sort of bumbling Mr. Magoo
who falls off bicycles
and wanders around stage
like an extra
in a Broadway show,
[ Laughter ]
accidentally entered too early
and is hoping no one notices.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
Hey, is it time
for "Mr. Mistoffelees" yet?
[ Laughter ]
No?
Mind if I just hang out here
until it is?
[ Laughter ]
But in reality,
Biden has, somehow,
spent two years scoring
one political win after another
and bucking historical trends,
while Republicans just
eat each other alive.
Joe Biden might secretly be
a political mastermind
who's just pretending
to be old and confused.
He's basically
President Doubtfire because...
[ Laughter ]
...while Biden's chowin' down
on cobbler,
Republicans are meltin' down
before our eyes
and proving to the nation they
just can't be trusted to govern.
-This is a portrait
of paralysis.
This is what the Republicans
have told the country
in the last two months.
Historic underperformance
in the midterm,
followed by historic
institutional chaos.
-I mean, this is --
I don't want to say
an unmitigated disaster
for Kevin McCarthy,
but it's close.
-It's pretty bad.
-Let's get back to our top story
right now,
the truly historic humiliation
of Congressman Kevin McCarthy.
-Wow, it is brutal when someone
as neutral as Wolf Blitzer
burns you that hard.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like if you got wasted
and [bleep] your pants
at a college party
and Walter Cronkite was there
[ Laughter ]
to report on it.
[ As Cronkite ]
A harrowing scene today
at Sigma Chi
as Kevin lost control
of his bowels
at 3 am Pacific time and...
[ Laughter ]
...defecated into his trousers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But it truly is humiliating.
McCarthy has now lost
eight straight votes
for speaker of the House.
This is the first time
in 100 years
it's taken even more
than one ballot
to elect a speaker,
let alone eight.
And the crazy thing is,
because nothing else can happen
until a speaker is elected,
McCarthy just has to sit there,
losing votes over and over.
[ Laughter ]
The only other thing
the House can do is adjourn,
but then when they come back
from adjournment,
they just have to vote again.
That's it.
McCarthy's stuck in some sort
of nightmarish
existential purgatory,
like the waiting room scene
in "Beetlejuice," you know, but,
[ Laughter ]
next to someone scarier
than anyone in that movie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He's lost eight times!
And, every time they hold one
of these votes,
it goes down pretty much
the exact same way.
They call the roll,
McCarthy loses,
they tally up the votes,
and the clerk announces
the results like this.
-A speaker has not been elected.
A speaker
has not been elected.
[ Laughter ]
A speaker has not been elected.
A speaker
has not been elected.
A speaker has not been elected.
A speaker
has not been elected.
A speaker has not been elected.
A speaker
has not been elected.
-It's like getting all the way
up to the altar
and then your fiancé(e) says,
"I don't,"
and, instead of going home,
the priest says,
"What do you say, everybody,
should we try it again?!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And everyone's like,
"Yeah! Ask again!"
[ Laughter ]
And it's especially funny
to watch Republicans try
to put a positive spin
on this embarrassing debacle.
For example,
they all keep insisting
that what we're actually seeing
is a healthy sign of democracy
and diversity of thought
within the Republican Party.
-Diversity of thought
is a good thing.
It's one of the things
that sets us apart
from our friends
on the other side of the aisle.
Yes, diversity of thought
is a good thing.
-It looks messy.
[ Laughter ]
But democracy is messy!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Democracy is messy!
By!
By design.
-Unlike Democrats,
members of the Republican Party,
they're not sheep who are --
you know,
will do what they are told.
-If you prefer real debates
about issues
that actually matter,
it's pretty refreshing
to see it.
Yes, it's a little chaotic,
but this is what
it's supposed to be.
-Yeah, watching Republicans
paralyze the government
and sit through a never-ending
existential hell
of bickering and name calling
is actually a good thing.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure Americans love it.
When voters see Lauren Boebert
and Marjorie Taylor Greene
screaming at each other
like two suburban hockey moms
[ Laughter ]
on opposite sides of a game,
I'm sure they can't help
but think to themselves...
-Yes to America.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, we'll say it.
I am in no rush
for this particular
House of Representatives
to get to work.
I mean, if Republicans
ever figure their [bleep] out,
it's just going to be two years
of Hunter Biden's laptop
and threats
to detonate the economy
and Anthony Fauci
in a dunk tank.
[ Laughter ]
So, by all means,
take your time.
Also, just a side note --
during one of those speeches,
Republicans accused Democrats
of drinking and eating popcorn
as they watched
the GOP [bleep]show unfold,
[ Laughter ]
prompting oohs
from the rest of the House.
-They want us divided.
They want us
to fight each other.
That much has been made clear
by the popcorn and blankets
and alcohol that is coming
over there.
[ Voices overlapping ]
-Oooooh!
[ Laughter ]
This whole thing is turning
into an episode of "Maury."
[ Laughter ]
Tonight's episode is called...
[ Theme plays ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, you might be thinking
it has to be against the rules
to drink alcohol
in the House of Representatives
and, to be clear, I have no idea
if that's what's happening,
but regardless,
it doesn't matter because,
until they elect a speaker,
there are no rules.
[ Laughter ]
It's a free-for-all.
They might as well be doing
these votes on a party boat
in Italy with Tanya.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, you may not know this,
but that's why C-SPAN has been
so kickass this week.
Normally, they're restricted
to one camera pointed
at a bunch of empty chairs,
but while this drags on,
they can basically film
whatever the hell they want.
They can whip around the chamber
like a squirrel wearing a GoPro.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And it's been amazing
this week.
We got to see Republican
election denier Paul Gosar
chewing off AOC's ear
while she made a face
like she'd rather
he literally chew it off.
[ Laughter ]
What Republicans are dealing
with right now is
the core problem
of the modern GOP,
a party that is
fundamentally broken.
This is the dynamic
Trump exposed,
but it also predated him.
Republicans were happy
to appease,
and even use the crazies
in their party to gain power,
but now, the crazies are
in power with them
and it's coming back to bite
Republicans in the ass.
It's like in high school
when you got invited
to a party one town over,
but the only person you know
who had a car was Weird Gary.
You'd say, "How bad can it be?
He'll drive us to the party
and then we can ditch him."
But then every time you start
talking to a cute girl,
Weird Gary would appear
right next to you,
[ Laughter ]
breathing all heavy.
He'd be like,
"Hey, I'm Seth's friend.
[ Laughter ]
Yes to America!"
Even Donald Trump can't seem
to rein in any of these people.
He's apparently
called them repeatedly
to lobby on behalf of McCarthy,
but after a recent
Trump phone call,
right-wing
Congressman Matt Gaetz,
one of the leaders in the
anti-McCarthy revolt, said...
[ Laughter ]
MAGA Republicans
are even starting
to turn around
and give orders to Trump,
like Colorado Congresswoman
Lauren Boebert,
who said, on the House floor,
that, instead of lobbying
on McCarthy's behalf,
Trump should call McCarthy
and tell McCarthy to drop out,
once again, prompting
some oohs from the chamber.
-Let's stop
with the campaign smears
and tactics to get people
to turn against us,
even having
my favorite president
call us and tell us we need
to knock this off.
I think it actually needs
to be reversed --
the president needs to tell
Kevin McCarthy that,
"Sir, you do not have the votes
and it's time to withdraw."
[ Oohs ]
With that, I yield.
Thank you.
-Oooooh!
[ Laughter ]
We're back with Part 2
of tonight's episode...
[ Theme plays ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then later that night,
Boebert appeared
on Sean Hannity's show
for a rare display of conflict
and it resulted
in this truly fantastic moment
where Boebert just started
throwing out names
for other speaker candidates
and it exasperated Hannity.
Couldn't handle it.
-Sean, I understand
the frustration,
I promise you, but --
-I'm not frustrated.
-He does not have the votes
-You didn't answer my question.
-and we are hearing --
-[ Strikes desk ]
-we are hearing from many people
-I'm not frustrated.
-who are still voting
with Kevin McCarthy,
who are very supportive.
-You're not answering
my question.
-I'm not going to support
-An answer
from a liberal.
-Kevin McCarthy, Sean.
-Okay. So, even if you only have
-I am not going
-30 votes...
-to support Kevin McCarthy.
-...you will not abide by
-If I am the last
-what you told President Trump.
-person standing...
-to abide by.
-...which I don't believe
I will be, I
-I got it. I feel like
-will not --
-we've made progress.
[ Laughter ]
-Look, I love President Trump.
You're not going
to turn me on him.
You're not going to pit him
against me.
-Not trying
to pit him against you.
-I love you. I love
President Trump and --
-That's what you said to him.
I'm asking you tonight --
who is your final choice
for speaker
and, if you can't get more than,
let's say, 30 votes,
will you follow your own advice,
that you were asking
Donald Trump, and withdraw?
-There are certainly names
that are being floated around
and, hey,
maybe I should nominate
President Donald J. Trump
tomorrow.
But, Sean, I did watch your show
last night and I want
to set the record straight
-Like we're going to pick --
-on this motion.
[ Laughter ]
-We're going to pick
-No, no, no, no, no.
-Jim Jordan one day...
-Listen, I want
-...Donalds the other day...
-to set the motion
-...Trump the next day?
-straight on --
[ Laughter ]
He literally said,
out loud, "Is this a game show?"
It is! You elected a literal
game show host, mother[bleep].
[ Laughter ]
This is truly --
[ Applause ]
They're all now saying --
They're all now saying
the same stuff
the rest of us said about them
for seven years.
You guys turned it
into a game show.
Just accept it.
Get Steve Harvey in there,
[ Laughter ]
have the McCarthys face off
against the Boeberts
and, every time they do
another failed roll call,
it can end like this --
-A speaker has not been elected.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, I guess --
I guess, technically --
I hate piling on,
but technically,
it would look like this.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Republicans are finally getting
their long overdue comeuppance.
They invited this chaos
because they thought
it would help them gain power
and, instead, they're the ones
who are eating each other alive.
They're proving,
over and over again,
to Americans
that they're a broken party
that is simply incapable
of governing.
For Kevin McCarthy,
this was supposed to be
a historic coronation,
and, instead, it's been a...
-Historic humiliation.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]